thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with a very happy victor of today's
round the final round and his first
victory in the event hardship first of
all congratulations we were expecting to
see you a bit more often here in the
studio with us but finally you are here
how would you assess your event
um yeah as alejandro mentioned
i did not have one of the best events by
far um i had some good moments but
there's it's at least nice to win the
last round so that i don't end the event
on a star note well let's go uh through
this game it seemed pretty smooth up
until the end game after that it was
very topsy-turvy let's see we'll just
take you to it because we were confused
by every move after that uh it was a
topsy-turvy game
up and up and up but we we got to this
end game which
i found i find as a chess player we're
not going to go through all these uh
mistakes yeah so actually a very tricky
decision was i could even take with the
knight on e5
and uh
i'm not completely sure which one is
better but i felt that it would be nicer
to have a like upon closer to the queen
so you cannot take on f4 after that yeah
g2 king takes you then because of knight
g6 my idea was that
um
so if it goes king to g7 yeah
no not here
so i thought that if i go king f3
let's say and if he ever goes h4
then i go
um f5
and uh if i if i just get knight g4 next
um he
i was not sure how to assist but this
was another way to play it and knight g4
and his king cannot really attack my
pawn right it's just boxed in by the
powerful knight controlling the dark
squares and the pawn controlling and the
light squares
but you took with the pawn tough to make
these decisions on move 40 for sure yeah
uh and we got to this end game and i was
going on and on and on and how lost this
is for black
i was not sure if it's lost to be honest
and apparently it isn't yeah because uh
so after um
knight c5
i i mean bishop c1 was possible i was
not
i don't think that's a big mistake
and actually it is a big mistake yeah he
had to go bishop bishop d2 yeah before
before no king j7 i think is still fine
was it yeah king j7 was still fine
knight c5 and then bishop d2 anyway
right
in this position maybe not no no you're
right bishop to d2 first i think it was
bishop d2 first that what we were
looking at
you go bishop d2 first and the idea is
that you forced to move c3
but i was also briefly considering
knight c i i didn't calculate as it was
i mean
uh
the time control just finished but i
might even consider knight c5 but yeah
and the thing is even if i get these two
connected past pawns because of the h1
it should just be a draw
the counter play yeah and the thing
things started surging here after uh the
move bishop c1
um
we were surprised by your move b3
did you consider the move b4
oh yeah okay now that i think about it i
played it in the game and yeah okay and
b4 bishop d2 d5 b5 yes just and then
what happened in the game yeah bishop a5
knight bison i kind of missed this right
and you either pick up the bishop or
this important pawn b3 but you must have
been happy though to see the move bishop
b2 on the board actually i was i mean i
felt that it's very difficult to defend
because he has many options like he
could even go king f7 he
could but i
but okay i think that after b4 i mean
knight b7 bishop e5 b4 i'm just winning
yeah this one is winning and you showed
a very nice technique [ __ ] g6 was
i mean everything is losing already so
it doesn't matter much but can you just
succeed i agree it's a strange move not
going towards the queen side
uh and after the move b5 you calculated
this quite nicely
actually
yeah let's see if the king was on f6 i
just win by one move
um instead of king g6 king f6
b5 ab5 a6
bishop
d4 bishop b it doesn't make sense
because after knight d8 i get an extra
move
so knight d6 b4
um bish knight b5
bishop somewhere
uh take stakes king e5 knight c6
and now we cannot go to d4 which
would have been nice but king d5 you get
to put the knife in before and knight
eight to one
yeah that's very nice our knight d3 also
works yeah yeah very nice calculation
there at the end how does it feel the to
starting such a bad note but be able to
pick yourself up and get those points
near the end
um yeah after the first three losses um
i was obviously very disappointed with
myself but
i mean in sports uh it's i think the
most important part of a tournament is
how you finish and uh at least i managed
to keep myself
in the game and in the tournament and
it's still not the best results but
i i can i can at least end it on a good
note and it was a very nice opportunity
for me to play her um with such a strong
field so
this is all also your first time playing
here at the st louis chess club what are
your impressions about the club about
the organization of the event
the organization was pretty top pretty
much top notch
also in the first
few rounds it took me a while to get a
com
to get a come like you know to get
accustomed to all the
um